hi everyone John roca here I am excited
to interview this gentleman on this
special interview episode for Collider
today he has been George McFly in Back
to the Future Phil in Hot Tub Time
Machine he was in the Charlie's Angels
franchise as a ruthless hit man named
The Thin Man
he was Amy Warhol in the doors which I
personally love is one of my favorite
biopics and recently you've seen him in
American Gods as mr. world and he has a
new film coming out this weekend this
Friday in theaters and on demand called
lucky day this thing is an incredibly
awesome mind trip of a film and he plays
an unpredictable and ruthless hit man
named Luke ladies and gentlemen please
welcome Crispin Glover how are you good
thank you for having me oh my pleasure
man you see the picture behind you this
is such an interesting character that I
don't think I've ever seen you play you
always play these kind of offbeat people
even though you know you could play
regular roles when their opportunity to
saw what George McFly but you always
have this tendency to add a little bit
of offbeat to them and certainly with
Luke there's an interesting aspect of
how did you get involved in this project
I had worked with Roger Avery on bail
wolf who were available with Neil Gaiman
okay which who of course gods as well
and and he had originally co-written out
with Neil to for himself to direct and
then Robert Zemeckis got hold of the
script and he wanted to direct it for
himself
it was because of Roger and Neil Robert
Zemeckis had said to them that they
would he would hire who he wanted who
they had put on their list of people to
play the characters and I was on the
list to play Grendel which I was very
surprised that I ended up working with
Robert Zemeckis again because there had
been a lawsuit for back to the second
Back to the Future film they put
prosthetics of another actors face yeah
it was illegal what they did anyhow is
it was very positive to have a really
nice positive experience again with some
echis despite what happens right I owed
that to Roger Neal so in great
to both of them and and then I was
always in the midst of touring with my
own we were talking a little bit before
my own shows and films I've directed a
couple of films and that in fact next
year I believe my next production which
have been working on for many years a
film from them I developed for myself
and my father to act and together it'll
be ready next year I'm quite certain
it's been in a long time I started
developing it in 2007 which is when I
premiered the second film of the trilogy
this is not part three of the trilogy
right and I and I started developing so
it's been more more than 10 years but
and started shooting it in 2013 ok
anyhow
that'll be ready sometime next year but
um so I was touring with my shows I
think I was also in check that's where I
shot the the newest production and
property there and I I got an email from
Roger and I was just in the middle of
touring touring on the film and then
Roger also called my father he was just
say I saw Roger last night we went out
for dinner with the cast it was nice and
he was saying that he he couldn't find
my number so he called my father a
father was say well if Crispin doesn't
do it all do it so but then I got the
the the the offer for the part I had to
start shooting I think it was 8
maybe it was exactly one week from that
when I got the the character Wow offer
when I started to I think that was true
for all of the cast luckily because it
was a good script yeah yeah yeah and
Rogers a good director and he cast well
it was it was fun yeah you you are fun
is the right word yeah to describe your
character in this film certainly a lot
of fun and something like you you handle
weapons in a way they haven't seen since
maybe Charlie's Angels right
and there's such a confidence in what
you're doing that is you know the great
thing about you men is when you get a
role do you really sink your teeth into
people get to be reminded of the talent
that you have this one sure it's like it
does depend on the role of a horse if
there's if there's depth within the role
then that's what you really want you you
can try to imbue and any role and
sometimes it worked
yeah but you usually if out depth isn't
there in the script it's very difficult
to get that in there there was depth in
this yes Roger you know he had been
incarcerated for an unfortunate accident
and this was a reflection of this he
told me about spirit he wrote this while
he was incarcerated or was a teenager on
you know under 18 and she was getting
the pages in in envelopes that was the
only thing they couldn't like I guess
chat write very very interesting story
but you can you can feel that there's
there's something really going on in
yeah yeah the story is this safecracker
name read is played by a Lou Bracy he
rejoins his wife Nina Dobrev and
daughter and they any vows to go
straight but when he's trying to go
straight this psychotic hitman which is
who Crispin plays here Luke he comes to
town seeking revenge against red for the
death of his brother and their I mean
the way you go about you don't even like
for an hour you don't see you don't
confront the guy telling right now we're
into the movies yeah we get a lot of
time with you
yeah and to say for the numerous ways
that you go about right killing people
when you when you're looking at it okay
and you talk about the script where did
the French accent come did you put that
I know I always say what that was
written oh yeah yeah yeah what did you
base that on did was there anyone that
you liked whose accent you wanted to go
on off of no cuz it was such a fast I
had never ever done this dialect yes
forever yeah and so in my life I'd never
attempted it even so so luckily there
were
there are professionals that you can
work with to help with this there were
certain things I had in mind I've I
actually won't see the film until Friday
well I I could have you know watch it on
my computer but I feel kind of like this
film is something where you want to see
it with an audience yeah so I I'm gonna
see it on Friday so I'm not sure I I'm
keeping my fingers crossed I felt very
good about it that's right I'm looking
I'm looking forward to seeing it but I I
don't know exactly how it's come off but
you know I know that the word even when
when it was before I got the part there
was like a well I think before I got the
part it was a one-line written that it
was a psychotic character in terms of
the actual definition of psychosis
I'm not sure that this character is
knows it maybe it comes off as psychotic
I can't tell but in in a certain way the
character isn't although there was one
thing that happened that got switched on
the day of shooting because in the
original script there was never there
was never an unmotivated kill
essentially yeah but but there was
something that got switched where we
just running out of time and they asked
if it was okay if we just if I drew a
gun on a particular character and it
didn't have the motivation so that I
maybe that would push it over to psych
psychosis but I have to I have to see
the film to see that it comes off place
was it clear that you're after this guy
for a reason it isn't until much later
that we discover why right right so we
have to and that has to be something
that we have to go along with and give
the film rope on so because hold a
minute will be explained as it goes on
but certainly you're the the magnanimous
nature of the character the the charm of
the character even though we have
rootless in his portrayal yeah is what
keeps us interested to seeing where this
final competition yeah there was a charm
in it yeah it's funny yeah did you enjoy
like kind of losing yourself into this
yeah no I really like I say it's it the
the the other thing that happens that
I've noticed for me that happened or
prettier
in my career is I would tend toward
early early early in my career I would
get characters perhaps that were less
eccentric but I would imbue it with
certain specifics which then tended
toward and has tended toward leading to
offers of characters that were written
as eccentric yeah which actually for me
I haven't fought it necessarily but
frankly I might it might seem surprising
I don't actually prefer necessarily
characters that are X written as
eccentric I prefer I mean I like
characters that have depth yes but but
if I prefer to put those elements in on
a character that is not necessarily
written that way yeah because I feel
like that then can give more of a depth
to it I mean obviously this character
does illegal criminal actions throughout
but I that's why the the word psychotic
I don't necessarily know that the
character is psychotic again I haven't
seen the film you sometimes you can't
tell how something comes off until you
see it but but in my own mindset I was
not thinking of this character as
psychotic I think when you use the word
ruthless or even I think the word
sadistic perhaps there's a little bit
sadistic I know but that which is
different from psychotic but again I've
got to see the film to know right so
this would imply though that you take a
special joy there's a psyche I think
more Psychopaths make sense because that
the value of human life is not relevant
to this person I may be incorrect with
that assumption but well a psychopath is
almost safer than so maybe but but but I
that again that's why that the element
about the the slight thing that got
changed with them being draw a drawing
first because I felt like in the initial
element of that it was always
specifically because I was trying to get
to this person right
so no matter what I whatever the the
peripheral damage was did not matter as
long as I got to that person which was a
revenge for personal reason which that
reveals revealing so III in a certain
way you could almost there's an
empathetic kind of an empathetic element
I mean that's what your job is an actor
yeah this is to do right you don't have
Plame just straight evil you got a some
sympathy for why this person is doing
what they're doing yeah Roger Avery you
talked about this you mentioned you know
a that he's this is his first I think
first film out of prison which you may
know he did another I know he did
another film look at Browns
okay actually right before this this was
almost like a to picture deal with uh
with the producer but but yeah so he I
don't know the what exact right he's
done between that my question is leading
into what was your experience with him
on the set making this movie and working
on this character how much input did you
have in the character what was the
process like with Roger yeah he's he's
great to work with really very easy I
feel you know genuine friendship with
Roger I'd known I I think I first met
him in the 90s even well before I ended
up working with Rio he's really nice to
talk to naturally get along with her
well and and he's also very clear on a
process of you know organic qualities
and actor will go through and wants to
work with what happens in the moments
and really and has a sense of humor yeah
it's certainly the film certainly has a
sense of humor got a lot of things I
know you haven't seen yet I got towards
it last night there is certainly a sense
of humor that he knows what to do with
the camera as well it's fascinating to
watch the cinematography is like
placement the camera the colors you use
is the locations the sets he puts you in
it never feels ham-handed or forced it
feels very natural within the offbeat
flow of the movie yeah I know he has
genuine talent yeah I'm glad he's
working yes yeah what what excites you
about roles you talk about this like you
know obviously we mentioned I mentioned
McFly George McFly to me that's pretty
much you know that's what everyone grows
up discovering you probably the first
time as kids
discovering back to future although
although it's funny as time goes on and
I've been in you know like you mentioned
Charlie's Angels or there's a film
called like Mike I did but but it's
funny because it's some of those kind of
kids films or younger films that I'll
you know I'll have people come up to me
that are you know grew up watching like
Mike or Charlie's Angels and of course
there's a lot of people with with back
to the future as well
but but it's funny how as time goes on
there's different things that come into
play and it's often about people that
have seen it when they were kids and
then they get it they're older and they
say oh I saw you and I was right well
what's not what's it take to get you
onto a set to do a movie cuz you do a
lot of things people just because you
don't see Crispin Glover doesn't mean
he's not working on a number of things
you mentioned the movie that you're
working on now it's taking ten years for
you know this thing so what what gets
you on to a set is it just the script is
that the character is it opportunity
timing what is it's it's always you know
it's some so many things especially you
know to have the lock or privilege or
whatever you want to call it of actually
having a career of making your living as
an actor yeah you know it's like you do
I do need to keep an income I'm not
perfectly independently wealthy right so
so and my phil i fund my own film so i
don't seek i mean i wouldn't mind if I
got but I don't know I I gave up trying
on getting other people to because I
like unusual right matter but you know
I'm straight as well right yes and and
it's also like the time that I take some
of it has to do with that I'm finding it
myself and I'm I'm producing it myself
and it
and in this particular film I acted in a
large part in it as well so taking the
time to figure things out throughout the
production was actually good for me and
then I like on my first film not on so
much on the second film but on this film
I changed them as I after I shot the
initial film and they became different
from what they were right and and it
took me time to figure that out and and
that is not how films are normally made
they make a script everybody says okay
that's what we're gonna do and then you
essentially edit the film you're more or
less to be like that script so changing
after what you've initiated would be
frowned upon heavily by and
understandably so by an investor yeah me
being the investor in my own film I can
have the argument with myself anybody
else would fire me and I know it and it
would and and and then I would be
frustrated in knowing that I could make
a better film and the other people would
you know they'd get a different director
or whatever editor and take it away from
me so it is worth it for me despite the
time I mean I'm I would like to make
films more rapidly and I actually aspire
toward doing that but it's made sense
for me to do it in the in the way that I
have but but in terms of and I will say
that even though it's not you know I've
never released my first two films
digitally so people have to see them
when I tour they can find out about them
on my Crispin Glover car yeah go -
Crispin Glover calm if you want to see
his I'll be in I'll be in San Francisco
I think at the Castro in January with
one of the films but and also I'll have
the new film the one with myself and my
father sometime next year ready you know
we'll see how I'm going to distribute
but but it it I it is what I even though
it's not what most people were thinking
of me about it is what's on my mind most
right and and yet then when I get jobs
as an actor I I take that seriously I
know I I go 100% into that as well which
is also why it takes time for me with my
own film so it's organic if I get a job
that makes sense for me to do and of
course there's different factors there's
character there's the the filmmakers
there's what you're going to get paid
you're it's where you're going to go how
it fits into schedule so many different
things but ultimately ideally it's that
you're wanting to get the character yeah
if it's a good character but you know
sometimes it's just like you need a job
you need to income so it all depends on
what's going on well that's the
breakdown of it all you know
I I found over the years is I've watched
her interviews and studied you like
there's the people have this perception
from the past but like sitting here
talking with you this is Christmas
Glover very much enjoyable gentleman to
be around talk and and work with but who
puts a lot of thought into things that
he's doing whether it be a high-end
studio film or an independent film yeah
and that has to be respected and I hope
that stigma breaks more because I know
that a lot of people love seeing you
when you pop up in a film do you have
aspirations for like their large like
what's your view on film now with the
superhero films and the blockbuster
films do you want it would you frown at
being asked to be a part of it well I
have not yet seen the Joker movie oh
yeah that seems to be you have a feeling
I'm gonna like it and I think it's a
good example of I know that I know I've
never met Joaquin Phoenix but I respect
him as an actor and I I know that he was
saying he said why not have a character
study that's a big superhero movie I
agree completely I have not yet seen the
film but I'm assuming I'm going to think
it's a good movie and I sure if you can
do something that has genuine you know
integrity to it and it and it's seen by
millions of people of course that's that
is is what
the ideal i-i-i-i
for my own my own filmmaking you know I
make my own films partially because I
want to do things that are that I find
of interest and if I were to have a
studio say to me we're going to give you
a hundred million to make your part 3 of
your trilogy fine oh I know that's not
going to happen that's ok I I I'm fine
either way but but no I have I have
nothing again
ai ai ai ai ai ai ai also will have a
book out next year that I've been
writing for many years and that subject
matter has to do with propaganda in in
entertainment how it functions and I
interesting ok it's something that
particularly my first film reacted to
but it's it's pretty prevalent in our in
our entertainment media but you know
things can break through every once in a
while even in in corporate work that
that can be of interest and are not just
for lack of a better word
military-industrial complex corporate
propaganda but but well this is lucky
they certainly isn't that lucky yeah and
you know they said there are simple
moralities in it yeah it's not I don't
want to spoil it but it's it's it's it's
it's fairly standard good morality what
happens I won't spoil it right yeah it
isn't it so it's a it's it's definitely
a throwback to the 90s that kind of vibe
you know obviously with Roger Avery from
killing Zoe and from laws of attraction
those interesting offbeat films at the
time when independent films were like
all the rage in the 90s yeah so any
co-wrote pulp engine right the oscar for
ryan residence which is still my
favorite tarantino film barn on no
matter what he
our dog still my favorite this is
something that is a fascinating thing to
walk back into this vibe yeah and it
must have been a joy and this is my I
know we're running out of time so
actually this last question it must have
been a joy to kind of bring that 90s
vibe back to a 2009 teen film well I
wasn't I wasn't thinking specifically
about that I think even Rogers mentioned
just wait what ya said for me I I almost
was thinking was the throwback even
previous to that Oh to me maybe the
1940s or something I I don't know I was
wrapped I loved your yeah they're kind
of you know a classic kind of gangster
yeah with a certain kind of style or
anything so I I don't know I again I
haven't seen it so I don't know what it
comes off like but but then they did I
did have that a little bit in my mind
but ya know I loved I loved working on
it I'm looking forward to seeing it with
an audience on Friday I think I'm going
to enjoy it I had a great time with the
character and it was is one that had
some genuine depth who have fun with
which I I did have that's for sure and
that comes through when you're watching
it this thing it is called lucky day
it's coming out as I said this Friday in
theaters and on demand don't miss this
if you grew up during that time or if
you want to just kind of not see the
mainstream blockbuster stuff and just
sit back and enjoy and have a fun time
in the theater and of course this is the
man who steals the show throughout it so
Crispin Glover thank you so much for
coming I really appreciate it yeah you
too thank you all right we'll talk to
you next time with another interview on
collider take care until then lucky day
don't forget it